you guys can't see this video but i
don't know if you guys saw this in west
virginia
there was a weird ufo spotted in the sky
that looked like
people are saying it's a ufo crashing to
earth because there's like
flames coming out of it check out this
video so this video was uploaded on the
27th
ufo crashing to earth caught on camera
in west virginia
now a lot of people have said it's
easily explained what you're looking at
is the contrails of a jet reflected
in the sunlight the issue is the trails
end in if you look up these uh sunset
contrails
i don't know this this channel is ghost
that hunt bag or something if you look
up
contrails from a jet in the sunlight
you'll see there's like it looks like
fire
but the the the the the what is it the
water vapor that comes out of the planes
stays there in this video it's really
weird it looks like
it looks like there's two distinct
streaks of fire coming out of some weird
object in the middle
nobody knows what what it is so far now
people are saying it's an airplane i
don't know for sure but i got good news
for everybody
because we have this omnibus bill right
yeah now now all
of a sudden people are like look i'm
here for aliens man i don't know what
you're talking about omnibus bill okay
hold on hold on 5 500 page bill
get sent to congress and somebody snuck
in
i'm assuming they snuck it in a
provision in this ridiculous bill nobody
read
something a provision mandating that the
pentagon
reveal their information on ufos
at least they got that and they could
have put there's so many things that
could have gone into this
they you know i don't i don't know how
these these government bills work where
no one reads it but someone knows what
they put in there
how does that work could you just be
like what if the aliens are writing a
bill
what what if what like how does this
bill work right do i get just like write
a provision saying i get a million
dollars and just slide it in nobody
reads it and they vote for it basically
so why doesn't anybody do that whoever
slid that in thank you
so much i appreciate you very much and
we need more of you now will
a lying government tell us the truth
about aliens
well that's a whole nother well let's
see what they say over at new york post
they say president trump's signature
sunday and the 2.3 trillion coveted 19
relief and government funding bill
started 180-day countdown for the
pentagon and spy
agencies to say what they know about
ufos
the provision received very little
attention in part because it wasn't
included in the text of the 5593 page
legislation but as a committee comment
attached to the annual intelligence
authorization act
which was rolled into the massive bill
the senate intelligence committee
chaired by marco rubio said in a comment
it directs the director of national
intelligence in consultation with the
secretary secretary of defense
and the heads of such other agencies to
submit a report within 180 days
of the date of the enactment of the act
to congressional intelligence and armed
service committees
on unidentified aerial phenomena the
report must
address observed airborne objects that
have not been identified
and should include a detailed analysis
of unidentified phenomena data collected
by
a geospa by a geospatial intelligence
b signals intelligence c human
intelligence and d
measurement and signals intelligence the
report must also contain
detailed analysis of data of the fbi
which was derived from investigations of
intrusions of unidentified aerial
phenomena data
over-restricted united states airspace
and an assessment of whether this
unidentified aerial phenomena activity
may be attributed to one or more
foreign adversaries what if they didn't
include
aliens then does the pentagon just not
get to tell us if it is
because they put four in adversaries
they say former pentagon and legislative
officials confirmed tuesday
to the publication the the debrief that
the packet uh that the package begins
the clock
on ufo disclosures so there's a lot more
uh
here's a quote from we got this guy
chris mellon former deputy assistant
director of defense intelligence
told the debrief the newly enacted
intelligence authorization act
incorporates the senate intelligence
committee's report
our committee's report language calling
for an unclassified all-source report
on uap phenomenon this was accomplished
in the joint uh
explanatory statement accompanying the
bill assuming the executive branch
honors this important request
the nation will at long last have an
objective basis
for assessing the validity of the issue
and its national security implications
this is an extraordinary and long
overdue opportunity so i want to go back
to that image
of that weird ufo that looks like it's
on fire and crashing down earth
what is it we'll never we won't know but
maybe
we'll find out soon huh i don't know man
like y'all do y'all believe it's
like aliens in general i don't know i
don't think it's aliens
no you don't think it is i believe in
aliens i don't know if that is aliens
but do you think that whatever after
talking to some high-level government
officials
do you think that personally told me
that aliens do exist yes i personally do
believe that
they're here though yes not in this room
specifically
i mean again we can't definitively prove
this without a shadow of a doubt
there is some circumstantial evidence
that i think is somewhat convincing but
this
year we have to also understand there
have been a lot of government admissions
when it comes to aliens
this is not the first time that this
subject was brought up
we have learned this year that the
government lied about a secret pentagon
unit
that they said never existed that's
tracking a lot of this stuff so they
actually
are doing something they do have some
data will they
share it with the american public that's
that's another thing but i think it's
probable
to believe that something else is out
there do i have definitive proof no i do
not
but isn't witness testimony
circumstantial evidence
yeah it's a certain circumstance we got
what's that dude in canada
um he's the former defense minister of
of canada
i got to look up his name to tell you
and he said yup they're aliens
well and then you've got the israeli
space security agency guys saying the
same thing this year yeah yeah yeah
former head of the israeli space program
came out and said
very similar things to what the former
minister of defense
for canada said is that there's a alien
federation
that there's aliens trying to keep the
peace the galactic federation
so i was thinking something i was i was
i was playing my ps5 the other day right
and there's this game i saw a trailer
for i think it's called stray
and i guess i don't the game is about i
guess you play cat but uh
yeah you see it and on the wall it says
rip humans
and then the people are actually all
robots and i thought about like what
would happen if humans created a bunch
of robots to do tasks then humans died
off what those robots do just keep going
i'm like what if
aliens created humans but then left and
now humans are like
that's why we're like what are we what's
our purpose we don't know we have all
these crazy philosophical questions
and the reality is we just don't have
one you know the aliens came made humans
left because they didn't need to
use human labor anymore and now they're
chilling watching be like what are they
doing they're like building cities why
they're not doing anything i have the
same question with this one that we
that i had with the one that happened in
china you know it apparently crashed
down to the earth
why don't we go to the site and see if
we can find any pieces of it did the
whole thing burn up is there absolutely
no evidence left
like why can't we find some kind of
something to tell us what it might have
been
because if it was just a jet it's up in
the air yeah i think we should begin it
start telling us what was there right
start start giving us the evidence and
proof of what
was actually there and then let the
people decide themselves you don't have
to tell us
who what where and and what specifically
you think happened
just show us exactly what happened and i
think that level of transparency that
level of accountability
is dearly needed within our government
and
uh i mean this is something i personally
want i was there at the storm area 51
protest
eagerly waiting livestream and
it was like it was like a cheap man's
burning man
but i'm still shocked how we went from
storm area 51 in one year to social
distance
stay home to stop the to stop the curve
or whatever
in just a matter of a year let me tell
you guys a crazy story do you guys ever
hear about the
the o'hare airport ufo yes from you so
i i worked for american eagle airlines
it's a regional airline for american
airlines
from 2004 2006 and then shortly after i
quit
a bunch of people working at the airport
saw a ufo come down from the clouds and
hover in place for a few minutes
and then shoot straight back up to the
clouds punching a hole in it
everybody at the airport saw everybody
working saw it so i knew a bunch of
people still worked there i had friends
who worked there and they were like dude
we saw it it was crazy i knew one dude
who said so there's a road
outside of o'hare airport called
mannheim road
and my my friend said people in their
cars were stopped like way at the light
and then when it came down from the sky
people got out of their cars and were
just staring at it
like just just like watching it this is
before the era of you know like the
iphone and a lot of smartphones
some people had phone cameras and so
there was a pilot
who looked out his window and he took a
picture of it and the photo actually
exists on google you can you can pull it
up
it's difficult to find because a bunch
of people made fake photos
yeah and it's it's a real bummer but the
real photo you can still find it
and you can you can faintly see it the
crazy thing is
where are all these people that got out
of their cars on manheim road and just
stood there staring at this ufo
and then they said it was it was a
weather phenomenon and i knew people who
worked at the airport they were like
dude no way
like it came down and hovered and you
could see it and then it shot sort of
punched a hole in the cloud what was
that
magnetic craft magnetic aluminum maybe
lightweight yeah i would imagine
something
you're actually describing with the ufo
yeah like a fusion power source and
being moved around by a magnet or
something
so does aliens no it's human oh
it's tesla could be yeah i mean there's
many people with many different beliefs
there's religious people who are talking
about demons
and other kind of energetic entities out
there there's of course conspiracy
theorists who are saying ufos aliens
there's other conspiracy theories saying
that this is advanced government
technology that they're keeping away
from the people
there's many different belief systems
out there but i think again
we should start with the government
telling us the truth and stop
classifying and hiding information from
the general public the problem i think
that's a great
flapper lied under oath blatantly and
they they lie about everything yeah
so i have zero
and i think that's they know that right
they don't have to say anything just
show us what happened yeah well that's
the thing
who knows what that's going to be though
you know the way they approach it is
that they're not i don't think they're
completely oblivious to the fact that
okay if we say that something
uh is going to happen they don't trust
us enough to tell the truth
right so like is is it even if they came
out with something said this is what it
was it was an alien the
the fear is that if aliens revealed
themselves to us the world would tear
itself apart
and i hear a lot of people who but hold
on people in america might be able to
accept it
people in the us might be like wow i
guess aliens we can accept like
it's like lizard people but what we are
carrying each other apart no no no no no
no what about
other cultures and other countries that
are way more fundamentalist
and would go insane and press the nuke
button and just go nuts
america i don't i don't think that would
happen you don't you think everyone in
the world would be like oh aliens are
real and then they're holding hands and
singing under the rainbow no
no i'll tell you what happened the
aliens would come here and then everyone
would be in competition to get access to
that technology
of course imagine if they already are
this is why china built one of the
largest kind of satellites in the world
trying to read uh signals from outer
space it's a weird argument because it's
like if dogs could talk
people would go crazy so maybe dogs can
talk what do you mean well i mean
are you purporting that there's aliens
because if they if there were they
wouldn't have
revealed themselves because if aliens
reveal themselves the world will tear it
back
that's one of the fears argument for
their being aliens because if dogs
are taught what do you what what does
that could fly but they never flew
ian what are you talking about i could
levitate but i don't have to do with
anything
are you making the argument that there
might be aliens because if
if they revealed themselves they would
drive people crazy so i'm not revealing
this i'm saying
what i'm saying there is a fear that if
aliens if the government did tell us the
truth and revealed to the world aliens
existed
it could cause internet but if the
government told us that dogs could talk
it might also
make international except they can't
what do you mean well
and there's no aliens what is what does
dogs talking have to do with light speed
travel and
and ion cannons and creating like you
you're suggesting like a dog's talking
your impossibility might be real no it
isn't aliens
aliens visiting earth is like a 0.00000
actually you're totally wrong what is
the actual likelihood that intelligent
life intelligent life exists in the
universe is
i believe i believe that and so there's
questions as to why we're not
encountering them because it's one
is called i think it's called the great
zoo hypothesis that they treat the earth
like a forest preserve and ignore it
there's a bunch of theories about this
but the mathematical probability that
aliens exist and that they're
substantially more advanced than us
is mathematically very high and so the
question in fermi's paradise is why
haven't we
seen them yet and there's a bunch of
different hypothetical answers as to why
that would be
so we don't know so what i'm saying is
i'm not saying aliens are here
i have no idea we have no evidence to
say that except for this the fantastic
reports of flying crazy vehicles at
o'hare and
and and you know or whatever but that
could just be military tech and it's
substantially more likely it is
but as i was pointing out one of the
concerns as we're talking about the
government keeping secrets is a fear
that if the world found out right now
about aliens that's what they say though
right that's why it's classified right
because people would lose their minds do
you think they would lose their mind
eric
that's i think i think it goes back to
culture
because that's a great point i think we
you know yes we have this sort of
diverse culture in america but if
when you talk to other cultures about um
you know nobody pockets of africa and
and like
that see the world just fundamentally
different than what it is that we do
i think that they would react in a
different way i think
a lot of americans come to term i think
it'd be a lot more curiosity
curiosity than anything because at that
point it's like if we get a confirmation
of something that we we assume that
we've seen all it's been
embedded in our culture aliens right we
got movies and movies and
x-files yeah yeah yeah show tv shows
like it's this assumption that
well we have this assumption and how
they look hell they might look like us
who knows uh
how exactly they will look but we have
all of these theories but
i think a lot of americans assume that
that's a thing now what they rip each
other apart is an interesting question
but i think that it would be more than
anything if there was an emotion
it would be more so a curiosity because
it's like if you confirmed right now
let's say if the
government said i win got like trump on
his way out scorched earth
i'm not gonna be the president bit bam
here's the proof right
here there's a video here's a video
here's his and his a man
and it's trump giving thumbs up yeah
yeah like and it's like oh
4k hd and everything they're eating
mcdonald's yeah
it's as advanced as you can possibly get
i think at that point i know at least
speaking on i'd be like just
curious like more than anything else
yeah i wouldn't want to fight my
neighbor yeah
what do you think would happen if a
video came out of trump hanging out with
aliens
china would go nuts china would declare
war or something that's a good teacher
and that's i think that's where it goes
back to the culture because it's like at
that point it's like oh wow
they have access to this advanced sort
of they're getting hooked up
right oh my god this is the real thing
so now
so who knows man that's a good point
according to these two high-level
government officials the canadian and
israeli one the aliens are the ones that
are specifically
stopping nuclear armageddon that's
according to again
uh the former head of the israeli space
program the canadian minister of defense
and uh he's saying that the humans are
not ready for them but the aliens are
here preventing a larger conflict from
expanding
i was watching some crazy thing about
orangutans fishing and stuff
you know okay like we're like we're
we're we're
more technologically advanced than they
are watching them do these things
like if there could come to a certain
point where we see animals fighting such
a way that we would stop them
we would be like man this is crazy if
imagine if we were watching you know
it's a thousand years in the future and
we're flying around with teleport packs
and jet packs and then the orangutans
now have nukes
yeah we'd probably stop them you know i
mean we'd be like dude you're gonna blow
everything up joe what are you doing
to advance so the aliens will come back
and you're saying like
what i'm saying is it makes sense that
aliens would stop us from blowing
ourselves up
because we'd be screwing everything up
you know there's very there's a
relatively small amount of planets that
sustain life and are in this
position assuming that they were here
which is a grand assumption i don't
think that they're that is nothing to do
what
that there is an advanced species here
that okay so anyway my point which
what you're saying has nothing to do is
with my point is that it makes sense for
human beings
to stop less advanced races from blowing
themselves up with bombs
like if you saw a bunch of orangutans
playing with dynamite you'd probably be
like whoa we got to stop though that's
crazy
and you'd probably stop them by any
means necessary because
you got a bunch of you know chimps and
monkeys playing with explosives
you would stop sometimes but when
monkeys hunt themselves in the woods you
don't
yeah because they're not playing with
dynamite and tnt if you think if they
were
like here's the video of the ship with
the ak-47 you ever see that one
the first cgi yeah yeah like if you saw
like a like an orangutan or a chimp pick
up an ar or something you'd be like
stop me and take it from it so that that
that idea
is interesting it makes sense that a
sufficiently advanced
species or or creature would stop
a uh less developed from plane with
crazy explosives i always think like
though
like what why do you think and i ask you
i'll
ask all of you guys why do we think that
the
assumption is that they are if they are
to exist they're more technologically
advanced than us
well but no no but it's all insanity
it's that if any
uh alien species is advanced enough to
come here
then they will be more advanced than us
yeah okay to such an extreme degree that
a lot of people need to understand a
couple things like
do you can you communicate with an ant
not really
i mean we can play with the pheromones
and make them walk in lines and stuff
but you can't exchange meaningful ideas
with them we can kind of understand what
they do and why they do it after being
studied
but it you know one of the things i was
watching this crazy documentary talking
about alien life and the components for
life
and the misconceptions people have about
aliens coming here and walking around
like they wouldn't even survive in our
atmosphere like by all mathematical
calculations about the variety of
elements we know of
they could have to exist in some kind of
weird methane atmosphere or something
but even if they did come here it's like
the the level of advancement
from a species you know able to travel
you know well beyond our understanding
in all likelihood would either be
substantially more advanced than we are
okay and that would be like you trying
to explain to an ant
how highway works but do you think like
on let's say other planets and whatnot
like that there are lesser advanced
beings
yeah definitely i think i think the
obvious like i think obviously you look
at the oceans of earth
humans are incredibly lucky when it
comes to creating computers and cameras
like if if we look at dolphins man
they're smart right
but they don't have thumbs so they can't
do anything not only that imagine
if dolphins had arms how are they going
to start a fire to actually
separate elements and create wires and
components
they can't do it underwater so even
dolphins
octopuses you know they got they can
manipulate stuff they got you know
but they can't do anything because
they're underwater i guess theoretically
they're like a lava vent and like you
know hold something close to try and
separate the iron out of the rock or
something like that
but we get fire we melt down you know a
rock you know we can separate the
elements and then we can slowly from
there start doing crazy things
i guess there's probably different
chemical reactions that could have
happened underwater
but there's probably planets with water
on it where you've got intelligent
beings
that just live underwater can't do
anything can't build a spaceship and
can't leave
there's actually what is it titan triton
what's the name of the moon
of uh triton i think is that saturn or
jupiter
jupiter saturn is titan isn't it titan
yeah there's like the one one of these
moons they think
could actually have liquid water because
the gravitational pull
of the the planet i don't know if it
said under jupiter is like causing it to
stretch back and forth which creates
friction which then
creates liquid water and there's they
say there could be life because where
there's liquid water there tends to be
life
but even if it was intelligent what's
going to do break through the crust and
then fly in outer space it won't be able
to do it yeah so it's just there
right so there's probably a lot of
intelligent alien life that doesn't have
the ability to create tools and
you know do anything like that there's a
lot of probabilities here but there's
there's one constant the government lies
that's the moral of the story thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you